tras seis meses recolectar pruebas y
evaluar documentos el autodenominado
tribunal we would ha llegado un
veredicto
el tribunal está convencido más allá de
toda duda razonable que la república
popular china al imponer medidas para
reducir los nacimientos tenía la
intención de destruir una proporción
significativa de la población uigur en
xinjiang por tanto cometió un genocidio
fueron claros y directos para los nueve
miembros de este tribunal informal
conformado por juristas y especialistas
en derechos humanos los testimonios de
abortos y esterilizaciones forzadas
sumados a las condiciones de
encarcelamiento y tortura infringidas a
los we gures permiten hacer esta
calificación este tribunal con sede en
londres independiente del sistema
judicial británico se creó a petición de
los representantes de los exiliados
uigures desde el inicio de su labor
beijing no ha dejado de desacreditarla
en reacción al veredicto en un
comunicado de prensa volvió a hablar de
falsa política
el lunes fue el gobierno de la región
autónoma de xinjiang el que atacó
preventivamente y el llamado tribunal
hoy fue creado por una conspiración de
las fuerzas anti chinas de eeuu y
occidente y de grupos del turkistán
oriental como el congreso mundial uigur
funciona como una organización anti
china y terrorista y no tiene
credibilidad el tribunal o gurb espera a
urgir al gobierno británico a que
reconozca lo que considera es un
genocidio hasta ahora sólo la
administración estadounidense se ha
manifestado a favor de ello en francia
la asamblea nacional tiene previsto
debatir el 20 de enero un proyecto de
ley que reconoce el genocidio we would